achim salée mais ressens un pincement au
coeur
chaque fois qu'il sort de chez lui car
son quartier cheikh jarrah à
jérusalem-est a beaucoup changé
des clôtures ont fait leur apparition et
des policiers lourdement armés ils sont
déployés pour protéger les israéliens
qui s'y sont installés
dans cette maison décorée de drapeaux
vivait auparavant une famille
palestinienne
elle a été évincée au profit de colons
israéliens
c'est très triste de voir une famille
entière jetés à la rue d'isle street
c'est ce qu'ils veulent faire avec tous
les palestiniens du quartier la menace
est bien réelle comme une demi douzaine
de familles du point h&m a été mise en
demeure de quitter la maison que sa
famille habite depuis 1956 un ordre
qu'il conteste devant les tribunaux
convaincu d'être dans son bon droit
nous avons tous les papiers qui prouve
que cette maison est à nous dit-il
documents émis par l'onu et la jordanie
mais les tribunaux israéliens ont une
autre interprétation
basé sur une loi israélienne nous avons
tenté sans succès d'obtenir la version
des avocats de la partie adverse
les colons israéliens du quartier n'ont
pas voulu nous parler eux non plus
news corp le tribunal n'est pas neutre
la firme à la la fille de hashim des
israéliens peuvent réclamer des
propriétés qu'ils habitaient avant 1948
mais nous n'y avons pas droit
ben oui car impossible sur l'art exemple
pour achim de retourner vivre sur la
terre d'où a été expulsé son grand-père
en 1967 un territoire
aujourd'hui conquis par l'état hébreu
deux poids deux mesures à l'origine de
la colère palestinienne et qui a
engendré le plus récent conflit armé
une injustice dénoncée aussi par
beaucoup d'israéliens chaque vendredi
ils se rassemblent à l'entrée de sheikh
jarrah pour protester contre
l'occupation de jérusalem-est et la
colonisation juives des territoires
palestiniens high tech etc total in just
s c'est une injustice totale que la
discrimination dénonça grito fran de
l'organisme la paix maintenant
anne fortune et les deux grammes et de
visuels et sa portée malheureusement
ajoute elle le gouvernement d'israël
chips y est les colons leur but est de
rendre jérusalem-est que juif pour
empêcher toute solution avec les
palestiniens
néanmoins du prophète sache ce look jeu
des nations unies l'afer est clair si
elles vont de l'avant les évictions vont
constituer une violation du droit
international car jérusalem est est
considérée comme faisant partie
intégrante du territoire palestinien en
tant que puissance occupante israël n'a
donc pas le droit de confisquer des
propriétés privées pas le droit non plus
d'y imposer sa loi
jérusalem ville sainte
tant pour les juifs que pour les
musulmans est depuis toujours au coeur
du conflit israélo-palestinien lutte
pour son contrôle se fait bien souvent
au détriment de simples citoyens
yadana par exemple a été forcé de
détruire lui-même la maison qu'il avait
construite sur un terrain qu'il dit
avoir reçu de son père essayé pendant
huit ans d'obtenir un permis de
construire dit il sans jamais avoir de
réponse là et lorsque la c il a fini par
lancer le chantier
les policiers israéliens sont arrivés
avec un ordre de la ville et un choix
cornélien démolir lui même sa maison ou
payer les autorités pour sa destruction
mais selon mes années bébour il
ressemble aujourd'hui une profonde
injustice en voyant des israéliens se
construire dans le quartier sans être
embêté mais ryad a juré de rester et se
bat tout comme achim et des douzaines
d'autres palestiniens de jérusalem est
convaincu que si la loi israélienne ne
leur est pas favorable
la justice elle est de leur côté ici
jean françois bélanger inde au canada
jérusalem est